bonjour que vous soyez de fidèles
abonnés ou que vous ayez cliquez ici en
espérant voir des kwh ailleurs cet
épisode est fait pour vous car nous
allons et parler des burgondes que
sait-on sur eux d'où venaient-ils
comment vivaient-ils quel héritage
ont-ils laissé et surtout apprécié et il
les fruits au sirop
c'est parti
[Musique]
je savais le code sorti on pense que les
burgondes viennent de ville de bornholm
dans la mer baltique
aux 1er et 2ème siècle après
jésus-christ les romains les appels
bergin johnny ou burgod younès qui
provient sûrement de l'inde aux
européens bureau du ce qui signifie
grand haut et fort fort en pommes au 1er
siècle et se déplace dans la région de
la vistule et la vallée de l'arve arta
ils y vivent tranquillement jusqu'à être
attaqué par un autre peuple
l'egypte ide qui les massacres fortement
et les forcent à partir plus au sud
ouest près du danube à la frontière de
l'empiré romain
à l'époque on connaissait vaguement ces
gens qui l'ancien les avait classé dans
la catégorie des vandales c'était des
germaniques en somme mais tant qu'il ne
franchissait pas la frontière on avait
peu de rapport avec eux à partir de là
ils vivent donc au bord de la frontière
est en contact avec d'autres peuples
notamment les alamans acquise essaye de
piquer des petits bouts de territoire de
temps en temps à cette époque leur
peuple est divisé en clans large
il est dirigé par un roi militaire
appelée and in hausse d'après l'écrivain
romain ammien marcellin ce roi peut être
déposée si la fortune à la guerre vient
à me manquer aussi les récoltes de films
trop mauvaise
chaque clan a aussi un dirigeant
religieux appelés sinistre us ce sont de
super gai comme ça qui lui est nommé à
vie et c'est à peu près tout ce qu'on
sait sur les burgondes jusqu'au 4e
siècle les sources archéologiques nous
confirment leur installation vers la
pologne puis leur migration à cause du
massacre des epide et voilà et puis vers
370 s'ils se sentent pousser des ailes
et fonde le premier royaume burgonde un
royaume de par bach l'ampleur l'ombre de
jean nono
en effet à la fin du 4e siècle ils
continuent de se déplacer et conquiert
le territoire des alamans dans la région
du maine proche du rat durant l'hiver
406 il profite que le fleuve soit gelée
pour lancer quelques expéditions au delà
du rhin dans l'empiré romain
ils ne sont pas les seuls des vandales d
alain et déçues elles franchissent aussi
les frontières de l'empiré à cette
époque
ouais on sait pas qui est coupable parmi
tous ces barbares mais les villes de
mayence et de wau ont été pillés et ça
se fait pas en parlant de mayence cette
villa bien portant dans la suite de
l'histoire puisque en 411 3 frères de
l'aristocratie locale décide de prendre
le pouvoir avec l'appui des burgondes
ces derniers nomme empereur
20 l'un des trois frères et s'avance
vers l' empire romain on se calme tout
de suite mais sur les barres war on vous
a battu samedi histoire
loin de là les burgondes vaincu négocié
avec le général romain et parviennent à
garder toutes les terres que l'empereur
autoproclamé jovin leur avait filé à
partir de 413 auront tout un territoire
dans la vallée du mail mais aussi en
gaule près du rhin qui correspond au
premier royaume burgonde ont il
semblerait que la capitale et était ones
dans ce premier royaume le mode de
gouvernement était simple tous les
frères d'une génération régner ensemble
puis lorsque le dernier mouraient les
enfants de l'aîné prenait le relais etc
c'est pour la famille ça sent surtout
les assassinats entre frères tout ça au
familia familiale en 436 c'est la
tristesse c'est la fin de ce premier
empire à cause d un qui envahissent le
pays dogon d'étu le grand roi green
d'art il est possible date il a en
personne et mener cette bataille
plusieurs sources romaines raconte cette
bataille et emploie l'expression absire
p pardon sédation être s'est il excusé
moi abce tire pas signifié dans la
langue barbare qu'est la vôtre à la
racine
ça semble donc indiquer que les uns ont
détruit la famille royale burgondes le
ska qui ne reste aucun héritier mâle
brommat à la place on met donc une
assemblée burgondes composée d'une
trentaine de types mais les burgondes
sont obligés de quitter leur territoire
en lui faisant un signe de la main parce
qu'ils vivaient dans la vallée du maine
fait semblant de rire on a retrouvé
quelques témoignages archéologiques qui
atteste de la présence des burgondes
dans cette région notamment à cimetière
a call and mind qui nous permet de
savoir que la plupart des burgondes été
incinéré mais en dehors de ça on a du
mal à distinguer les vestiges burgondes
des vestiges des autres peuples de la
région
passons donc au 2e royaume burgonde
encore une fois ce royaume se fait en
accord avec les romains puisqu'il
résulte d'un traité passé en 443 qui
accorde au bio grow le territoire de
l'aca podium trop cool c'est où ça peut
dia signifie savoie enfin quoique ce
territoire semble plutôt correspondre au
lac léman et au nord-est de ce dernier
ouais donc pas du tout la savoie quoi
merci pour l'info
on pense que ces nouveaux blanc compte
déplacer étaient entre 25 et 50 pire par
la suite vers 457 les agrandissent leur
territoire vers la gaule ils sont alors
menées par le roi gonds diop qui
s'installe à lyon et reçoit le titre de
magistère milite um
le maître de la milice parce que les
romains c'est des copains bien sûr ces
territoires étaient déjà occupées par
des gallo romains mais certains autres
peuples
du coup les burgondes s'installe selon
le principe de l'incrusté le partage des
terres avec les locaux que ça leur
plaise ou pas après bon diop vient leroy
hill peric dont on retiendra de lui pour
aller à l'essentiel kilmer entre 474 et
480 à dieu il peric voix dont on ne
parlera pas par souci d'audience à sa
mort ses deux fils se partagent le
territoire toujours selon le même
principe de succession du coup god
gisèle prend les territoires bio compte
de la sapo dia qui n'est pas la savoie
et gondebaud qui est l'aîné prend le
reste du territoire
tout ceci ressemble à un mauvais
scénario ou petit frère va se rebeller
pour essayer prendre les terres et c'est
ce qui va se passer mais pas tout de
suite d'abord gondebaud marie sa nièce
clotilde à clovis un mec vaguement connu
si vous avez suivi un peu les cours
d'histoire à l'école un jour il s'est
fait baptiser certains chroniqueurs
raconte qu'avant de marier sa nièce à
clovis gombo aurait massacré ses parents
et l'aurait séquestrée à genève où des
ambassadeurs de clovis l'aurait aperçu
et aurait rapporté à leurs voix m et le
même pas mal à genève
mais c'est un peu bizarre cette histoire
on sait pas trop pourquoi et leur ai
fait ça donc il est possible que ce soit
une confusion avec un autre événement en
tout cas la loi de bergon prévoit
effectivement des peines de
responsabilité familiale où on tue la
femme et les fils de [ __ ] 14 ans de
quelqu'un qui aurait vraiment déconné
donc ma foi donc les burgondes nouent
des liens avec les francs et ça tombe
bien puisque vers 500 go jiselle en a un
peu marre d'avoir les plus petites
terres du royaume son frère approche de
la cinquantaine et semble toujours pas
décidé à mourir alors il s'allie avec
clovis et décide de marcher sur les
terres de son frère solaire
quand gombo voix la coalition son frère
clovis il se barre clovis la siège à
avignon mais lui impose de lui verser un
tribut annuel mais c'est pas fini
une fois que l'eau vite reparti gombo se
rend à vienne où se trouve son frère
assiègent la ville tu son frère tu ses
partisans noah sa femme tue ses fils
jette tout le monde dans un puits et ont
fait enfermer les fils la famille
après ça gombo est libre d'unifier le
royaume burgonde tranquille il meurt en
516 etc sigismond qui lui succède lui
est plus posé que son père plus réfléchi
il fait trembler son fils sur un coup de
tête à 522 et regrette le soir même mais
je me souviens de ça ça ne serait pas un
événement qui marque le début de la fin
pour les deux gangs ce meurtre affaibli
le royaume burgonde parce qu'il pose
problème à l'aristocratie sur plusieurs
niveaux
déjà c'est un meurtre c'est puni par la
loi ensuite il a supprimé un héritier
potentiel ce qui est un peu con et
troisièmement ça montre que sigismond
n'est peut-être pas très apte à régner
sans déconner les fils de clovis décide
alors de conquérir toute la gaule et
commence par le royaume burgonde ce qui
est légitime puisque leur mère était
burgondes ils tuent sigismond et sa
famille mais ne prennent pas le royaume
tout de suite ségo thomas le frère de
ces gisements qui prend le royaume et
règne à partir de 524 lui est vraiment
plus posé il convoque des assemblées
essaye de ramener la situation à la
normale grâce à des lois exceptionnelle
en rhdp plans les campagnes par exemple
il rachète aussi des prisonniers qui
avaient été capturés par les francs et
des esclaves qui avaient été capturés et
qui reviennent sont libérés et sont
autorisés à s'installer sur place
ce gentil mais ce bonheur ne dure pas en
532 les fils de clovis reviennent à
l'attaqué et bat définitivement les
burgondes lors de la bataille d'autun
gaudemar disparaît on l'envoie jamais et
le deuxième rayon de l'aube monde est
intégré au royaume franc mais au final
comme les fils de clovis était également
à moitié burgondes tout ça reste une
histoire de bataille entre coude encore
une fois on conserve très peu de
vestiges de ce deuxième royaume parce
qu'on n'arrive pas vraiment à distinguer
des autres constructions des autres
peuples de l'époque on trouve quelques
vestiges dans la région d'annecy
dijon de chalon sur saône etc en plus ça
dépote burgondes on était revenu à des
constructions en bois plutôt qu'en
pierre alors éclate toi allez retrouver
1500 ans après les routes faute il ou
pas changé assiette pour fromage
tout ceci était fort chronologique alors
on va maintenant revenir sur quelques
points qui nous permettront
d'appréhender un peu mieux la culture
bio la culture burgondes je savais même
pas qu'il y en avait une vous avez pu
remarquer que dès le premier royaume
burgonde les liens entre les burgondes
et les romains étaient assez resserrées
à partir de leur installation dans sa
peau dia et participe régulièrement à
des batailles aux côtés des romains ça
amène parfois des petites particularités
comme une bataille contre attila en 450
dans la région de troyes où les
burgondes alliés aux romains se retrouve
face à d'autres burgondes dans l'armée
d'attila qui s'était soumis à lui lors
du premier royaume leur ont dès le début
de la nahda tahrir c'est déjà le merdier
et au sein de la famille royale les
burgondes reçoivent une culture
classique et par le latin les rois
burgondes se considèrent comme des
lieutenants de l'empereur romain
puisqu'il avait reçu le titre de
magistère me lie to me il frappe aussi
une monnaie à son effigie tout n'est pas
toujours rose non plus entre les
burgondes et les gallo romains comme je
le disais précédemment les terres
allouées aux burgondes contenait déjà
des gens dessus les s'installe donc
selon le principe de l'hospitalité deux
tiers des terres et un tiers des
esclaves reviennent au burgondes c'est
de la bonne hospitalité les historiens
se demande s'il est bien content
vraiment raflé une partie des terres des
esclaves ou s'ils ont juste reçu le
droit de prélever des impôts dessus ça
paraîtrait plus logique parce que sinon
on imagine qu'ils auraient pas mal de
révolte de la part des locaux
on a quand même des burgondes qui
s'installent sur des terres romaine où
vivent des romains et la cohabitation
n'est pas toujours aisé l'écrivain
gallo-romain sidoine apollinaire reçoit
ainsi quelques dizaines de bureaux
compte sur ses terres à l'occasion du
mariage d'un ami il rédige un poème dans
lequel on sent qu'il avait besoin de se
lâcher sur ses hôtes
pourquoi me demande tu de composer en
seraient même capables un poème en
l'honneur de vénus a mis des chances et
senna quand je vis au milieu dehors de
cheveux lui que j'ai à supporter leur
langage germanique et allouer un
continent malgré mon humeur noire
les chansons du bo gongga vecchi
s'enduit les cheveux de beurre rance
heurté yeux et des oreilles
heureux aussi ton et toi qui n'a pas à
subir l'odeur de l'ail de l'oignon
infecte que renvoi dès le petit matin 10
préparations culinaires toi qui n'es pas
assailli avant même le lever du jour
comme si tu étais leurs vieux grand-père
ou le mari de leur nourrice par une
foule de géant si nombreux et si grand
capelle les contiendrait la cuisine
d'alcine russe ou pau le texte le plus
important qu'on conserve des burgondes
et la loi burgondes on appelle aussi loi
gombe est puisqu'elle est profané par le
roi gonds de vauvert 500 de ce recueil
de loi pose les bases du droit de civils
et criminels en territoire burgondes et
réalise une belle fusion entre le droit
romain et germaniques
c'est le premier recueil de lois d'un
roi germanique en gaule se défend et des
wisigoths sont plus tardifs en fait ce
combo rédige de loi l'alex bourgogne où
nous qui régit les cas entre bio monde
ou en train de le gronder quelqu'un d'un
notre peuple est là l'ex romana
bourgogne où nous qui régit les cas
entre les gallo romains sur le
territoire burgondie la loi berglund et
surtout fait de droit romain mais
apporte certains usages germanique comme
le oui timone qui est la somme versée
par le fiancé à la famille de sa future
fans et le morginois b qui désigne les
meubles donné par le mari à sa femme le
lendemain du mariage
on trouve aussi des compensations
payable pour les blessures et les moeurs
des lois sur des vols mariage le divorce
la succession etc
la loi parlait beaucoup des esclaves et
aussi des fans l'autorité de la mère de
famille y est reconnue et c'est la seule
loi qui permet aux maires d'être tutrice
de leurs enfants mineurs tant qu'elle ne
se remarie temps enfin à côté de ça elle
prévoit de condamner la femme d'un mec
tu as fait quelque chose de vraiment
grave donc faut pas trop s'emballer la
loi burgondes et retravailler deux
parties successeur sigismond et gaudemar
et reste en place longtemps après la fin
du royaume burgonde évidemment elle est
faite de droit romain
donc forcément fait pour durer rappel
nous comment aller l'empiré romain au
cinquième siècle
tout ce que je pensais on ne peut pas
parler des blancs contre sens aborder
leur religion à la base des burgondes et
polythéistes
mais ils se convertissent à l'arianisme
vers 428 c'est une sorte de
christianisme
cette religion reste bien implantée chez
les burgondes durant le vème siècle
même si dans la famille royale les
reines et princesses rapportés étaient
catholiques
le premier roi burgondes à se convertir
au catholicisme et sigismond vers 500 du
coup comme on n'est pas sûr de la date
du baptême de clovis il est possible
qu'ils se soient converties avant lui d
eau pour la postérité
sigismond est tellement cateau qu'il
fonde une abbaye à saint maurice
d'agaune en 515 parce que ça fait
toujours bien au moment du bilan de son
règne de dire qu'on a fondé une abbaye
et qu'on a tué son fils non
cette conversion n'est toutefois pas
représentative de l'ensemble du peuple
paie en compte qui reste largement à
rien au 6e siècle
maintenant si vous rêviez de devenir
interprète burgondes je vous préviens ça
va être compliqué on sait qu'il existait
une langue burgondes mais on en connaît
très peu de choses mais quelques
exemples qu'on en a retrouvé était écrit
en alphabet latin
donc ça nous permet de constater qu'il
s'agissait d'une langue germanique mais
les paires ronde par les eaux si le bas
latin et à partir du viiie siècle la
langue bleue ronde a dû disparaître au
profit d'un mélange de latin de francs
et bourdon
vous voulez quand même vous la péter
sachez que chef de famille se dit farah
man époque le se dit le disent et
chambres souterraines ces escrocs n'ya
bravo vous voilà interprète burgondes
est désolé je ne sais pas comment on dit
qu hier en bourgogne dans les noms des
burgondes on retrouve aussi des éléments
germanique et à ce sujet la loi biyogo
des très précieuse puisqu'elle contient
les signatures de 32 compte burgondes et
du coup on alors non les suffixe préfixe
et non burgondes souvent une
signification et on retrouve souvent les
mêmes
comme si guy pour victoire bad pour
hardy des odes pour peuple wulf pour
wolf pour vous en faites
chez les femmes la mode est à bergame
qui signifie protection ou le bas qui
signifie cher aimé les noms dans la
famille royale se transmettent aussi des
parents aux enfants par exemple du roy
guy bika au roi gaudemar en passant par
seconde iops les noms commencent par
j'ai bien vu et ensuite sigismeau dont
le nom signifie victoire nomme son fils
si j strict mais il finit par le tuer si
vous avez bien suivi donc victoire mes
fesses et on a à peu près le fait le
tour de la culture du regret je sais
c'est triste mais si camelot avait
raison sur un point c'est bien celui des
barbares on vous dit il ne savait que
boire et manger et leur nourriture santé
horriblement fort il faisait mijoter des
ragoûts pendant des heures et ne
mangeait même pas de fromage pardon oui
c'est sidoine apollinaire qui me l'a
racontée par changer ce n'est pas un
mythe s'effondre
en dehors de ça on sait que les bourdons
de travail est bien le bois d'ailleurs
la spécialisation moderne du jura dans
l'horlogerie et les jouets en bois
pourrait venir de là on a retrouvé
certains objets de leur compte comme des
épées des petites cages des fibules mais
on ne sait pas comment elles étaient
armés comme il faisait partie de l'armée
romaine on suppose qu'ils étaient
équipés comme des membres de l'armée
romaine
les hommes portaient des tuniques jusque
mi cuisses et des braies ainsi que des
manteaux qui étaient des sortes de cas
attaché sur l'épaule comme les romains
imitateur et dernier point pas très
reluisant sur la culture burgondes il
pratiquait comme plusieurs autres
peuples de l'époque la déformation de la
boîte crânienne des enfants se sentir
tout à fait pas l'innocent monsieur
burgondes on sait vous mettiez des
bandeaux sur les têtes de vos enfants
pour leur donner des craintes pointu ça
n'est pas chez les romains qu'on
trouverait des pentes y paraît
l'histoire des burgondes ne s'arrête pas
à la défaite de gaudemar en 532 même si
le royaume burgonde n'existe plus les
personnes qui restent sur l'ancien
territoire burgondes sont toujours
burgondes et s'en revendiquent vers 536
un noble burgondes demande
d'autorisation de retirer du puits les
restes de sigismond et de sa femme qui
avaient été jetés après leur mort
l'histoire de leur rendre quand même un
petit peu dommage
même s'il avait tué son fils vers la
même époque le partage des terres du
royaume franc attribue la burgondie
hague contre ans l'un des petits fils de
clovis qui entretient la légitimité
burgondes puisqu'il a ça dans le sang et
que son nom a une racine but revendre le
nom de pure guia ou burgondie entre dans
les usages
après la fin du iième royaume burgonde
en 888 rodolphe le fils d'un conte
locale décide de devenir libres et
indépendants et fonde le troisième au
royaume burgonde oui enfin rien à voir
avec les deux précédents en 1 888 alors
tu arrêtes tes salades la romaine la
sèvre en parler bref ce troisième
royaume burgonde prend fin en 1032 on
sait qu'à cette période la loi burgondes
était encore utilisé
même si les royaume burgonde ont disparu
depuis longtemps et que les burgondes
dans le temps de se mélanger avec tous
les autres peuples locaux la burgondes
il reste considéré comme une entité à
part il ya une sorte de sentiment
national burgondes puis bourguignons qui
encore revendiqué par les ducs de
bourgogne au xvème siècle philippe le
hardi jean-sans-peur philippe lebon
charles le téméraire dans la toponymie
les noms des lieux on retrouve la marque
des burgondes un peu partout déjà dans
le mot bourgogne de manière assez
évidente qui est appelée burundi a à
l'époque frank
il existe aussi des villes comme
bourguignons les conflent bourguignons
les moret d'autres villes ont des noms
issus de mots germanique qui ont
probablement aussi été ramenés par les
burgondes le mot phare qui signifie
familles se retrouvent à montferrand
l'as far dans la drôme la sphère dans
l'aisne l'as far dans le veau on
retrouve aussi l'élément wulf qui
signifie loup dans les villes de vos
flancs juifs lance la ville etc
les bons comptes demeure aussi par
d'autres moyens on les retrouve par
exemple dans plusieurs états et saga
nordique écrites entre le 9e et le xiiie
siècle donc bien après leur disparition
les figures notamment dans l'état de
sonora
simplement la plus célèbre mais aussi
dans le nid blunden lead l'épopée qui
inspire l opéra de wagner
les personnages sont fictifs mais il est
possible que la grosse défaite subie par
les burgondes en 436 celles qui les
conduit à fuir leur premier royaume est
inspiré la malédiction des nibelungen
dans beaucoup des da l'histoire finit
mal comme pour les blancs contre 436
donc cellier voilà voilà j'espère que ce
petit tour dans le haut moyen-âge vous a
plu pour cet épisode je me suis aidé des
travaux de katalin pêcheurs qui a écrit
plusieurs livres sur les burgondes
malgré le peu d'informations dont on
dispose à leur sujet vous avez pu voir
avec le peu d'illustration que j'ai
utilisé cette fois je vais sûrement
faire une petite pause pendant l'été
puisque je vais pas mal bougé et je
serai notamment à montbazon les week end
du 22 et 23 juillet donc si vous y êtes
vous pourrez voir une conférence le
dimanche 12h15 sur le bon et le mauvais
sorcier à bientôt bisous ou abonnez-vous
et tout ça mon petit oiseau a pris sa
volée mon petit oiseau a appris ça
roulait à prix sa part la voile à deux
ris à la volette puis sa volée est allé
se mettre au sur 1 d'oranger et aller se
mettre sur un oranger sur un ovale à
voter sur nos à la volette sûr nous
ranger la branche était sèche cheveux
elle s'est cassée la branche était sèche
neil s'est cassée elle ne sais pas la
date de ces cas là vous êtes s'est cassé
mon petit oiseau où veux-tu te soigner
mon petit oiseau peux-tu te soigner
veux-tu te veux tu te à la volette
veux-tu te soigner je veux me soigner et
me marie je veux me soigner et mariée et
maman
à la bonne heure
mba à la volette vais me marier me
marier bien vite sur un d'orange et me
marier bien vite sur un oranger sur un
ovale a volé tout sur un homme à la voix
lâche 2 / à nous ranger